I wanted to see big Jay oakerson and
Bobby Kelly do their crowd work show
right because I think they're both so
[__] funny right and so quick big J
is like
he'll go anywhere with his jokes he's
great at bringing people back in I had
taken
I'm probably one and a half two grams of
mushrooms because I was gonna go watch
and then Brian Dorfman who is
just dude my favorite he owns Zanies
and he was like hey dude you should hop
on stage tonight and I was like this is
a bad idea
this is a bad idea yeah I'm
I'm
having a great time but
my focus isn't going to be good and yo
dude this show with big J and and Bobby
first of all I felt really bad a a a
legend
Killer Bees a legend I don't know who
that is I know in comedy especially
Southern comedy Southeastern part of the
states this dude has been selling
tickets for years so dwarf was like hey
why don't you and killer bees go on
together and I was thinking myself this
is a bad idea you know I saw kill bees
we already smoked pot with him and his
wife because they're great and
everything and endorphin goes you should
put on killer bees you should put on the
crowd which he goes crowd work's not his
thing at all it'll be really funny he's
even saying he doesn't want to and
shouldn't but I'm saying he should go on
I was like yeah I don't know you know if
he wants to if he wants to do it he goes
he wants to do it he's saying he doesn't
want to and that he can't do it but
he'll be great
he's like just go on with him like do it
with him he's putting that one on me
again and I'm like
I'm like I don't want to do that no at
all and then inside is Josh Wolf who's
on mushrooms and Josh Wolf now dorfman's
gone goes like Josh was like should I go
up on this thing and then Dorfman in his
drunkenness goes you guys should go on
together and I was like yeah yeah I
thought that was I pushed that out of
the eggs I'm like now I don't have to be
on stage at all yeah
dude so I go up on stage and I bring up
two I go two you know magazine comedians
coming up here
um and I go Josh Wolf and killer bees
and they clap when I'm on mushrooms
I'm not letting anybody else talk you're
gonna you're gonna out talk to Killer
Bees you [__] you're gonna talk
anybody I'm gonna I'll talk myself yeah
do you know yeah yeah that is true
sometimes you have too many words oh
dude that come out before your thought
process yeah yeah
Josh Wolf on mushrooms grabs the
microphone and puts a foot up on the
monitor in the front of the stage and
just starts working the crowd like he's
doing the job
killer beat and Bobby I need your
perspective on this because I'm watching
it from the back Killer Bees just held a
drink and just like stood not near a
microphone the whole time just like Josh
he just observed Josh Wolf working the
stage the audience on from on stage he
just stood there there's an old man
standing there holding a tree he looked
he looks crazy so it was a crowd work
show
man this me and this dude who is a
legend in comedy get on stage together
and I don't know how long we were on
stage together when I finally turned
around and I thought oh he's up here too
he had already put the microphone back
in the stand
and was standing like two feet away from
it just like
um yeah dude I fell so I kept trying to
that conclude him afterwards but it was
over I was in the crowd and he was
talking he was doing crowd work yeah but
the microphone was five feet away from
his face and I kept going Hey sir
I don't know if I'm gonna [__] burn a
bridge somewhere I'm like sir you need
this because Bobby was known Bobby's
really like he's not even throwing like
the Elder like comic respect and he's
going like I think Bobby Womack was like
because if he because you should
probably know this one you have to say
no microphone you dummy
microphone works you have
you have it for the rest of us to hear
you and he's just walking around going I
was [__] dude my blood sugar was low
my feet were hurting oh and he stuck out
this guy who was sciatica was acting up
dude he kept getting furious he goes and
Jay's outside smoking cigarettes and
weed with everybody and I was [__]
nuts every comic went on stage I'd go
outside I'm like oh it's time for a
cigarette oh it's on and they go hey I
gotta go get the person off stage I'll
be back out in two minutes you come in
Bobby's delivering [__] martinis to
tables I was sitting by the door I could
hear the fun
I could hear and I'm out there and the
guy's going what do I do now I'm like do
[__] talk to them it was totally my
fault I apolog this is how bad it was
not only did I apologize to him after
the show I apologize to his wife oof
that's the mushrooms talking though yeah
but dude that's for sure the motion was
talking can I tell you I apologized in
such a I love you man kind of way it was
looking back on it it's embarrassing he
probably doesn't ever want to see you no
he doesn't because you know what he said
to me after I apologized to him good
talk man
that's like giving somebody a thumbs up
yeah dude it was a I don't blame him
he's a like I said a [__] Legend
and I just went I shroomed out on him
and I think Not only was I super shrew
me
but he was super stoned so the energy
was just like mismatched yeah yeah yeah
I felt I felt really really bad if you
were both stoned it would have been
probably a little different
but you being on mushrooms and him just
being regular High
it's two different it's just levels
there's levels to it yeah and those are
for sure two different levels I think I
like me on stage on mushrooms more than
on weed
because on weed I'm I'm slowing the pace
down and on weed honestly I'm in my head
some I'm mushrooms I'm just I'm just
rolling and so I might do it once a
weekend I think here's what I'm thinking
I think Friday night late show
might just be the mushroom show
I like to smoke weed
I like to smoke weed bring it
[Applause]
[Music]